hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown 62 year old
frank james the man suspected of opening
fire and throwing smoke grenades inside
a new york city subway car injuring 23
people is in federal custody following
around the clock manhunt former new york
city police commissioner howard safer
shares his thoughts on how officials
handled the rush hour attack and what
can be done to address a surge of
violent crime in cities across the u.s
tv personality kathy lee gifford joins
fox nation with her new show about faith
and friendship the jesus i know she
joins the rundown to discuss the
five-part series her book by the same
name and shares whether she misses
morning television plus commentary by
fox news contributor pastor robert
jeffress the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we take a deeper look
at the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm cat tim i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner and this is the fox news
rundown
friday april 15 2022 i'm chris foster
the brooklyn subway shooting suspects in
custody a lot of criminals in new york
and other cities though are not and
crime is up when i was police
commissioner it was pretty clear if you
committed a crime everything from
jumping over a subway turnstile to using
a gun you're going to be apprehended and
you're going to go to rikers and then
you're going to go to jail all of that
over the last seven years has
disappeared we speak with former nypd
commissioner howard safer
i'm lisa brady with so much suffering in
the world it's not easy to keep the
faith but sometimes inspiration shines
through people lose hope and they lose
faith and they and they start to fall
into despair
i'm praying that those are the people
that watch this special or read this
book or any of my books and find hope
because god loves them we speak with
kathie lee gifford
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
now in custody facing federal terrorism
charges the man accused of throwing
smoke bombs and shooting 10 people
somehow killing none on a subway train
in brook with new york mayor eric adams
frank james was caught about 30 hours
after the attack and if convicted he
will face a sentence of up to life
imprisonment three on peace u.s attorney
for the eastern district of new york
james called a tip line to report his
location the day after getting away the
fact is you know there's hundreds of
thousands of people running through a
subway station
unfortunately but not surprising the mta
cameras didn't work so they weren't able
to track them and you know the crime
stoppers worked both for him and for
citizens howard safer former new york
city police commissioner there's a crime
stoppers unit at one police plaza it it
simultaneously gets on the dispatch
channel as well and they can dispatch
almost instantaneously it's like any
emergency call but if somebody calls up
and says i'm frank james i'm you're
looking for me that'll get their
attention immediately
you mentioned you mentioned the cameras
in the station
um some other criticisms that i'm not
sure would have stopped the attack or
gotten them caught any faster but
addressed them for me from your
perspective um the camera's there
um not not a police issue but uh
an mta issue uh he was able to get away
yeah go ahead
i'm pretty familiar with mta uh
technology from a number of years ago in
fact i was asked to look at it and it
ended up in a giant lawsuit between
the original integrator who had a 600
million dollar contract with the mta and
ended up doing all kinds of bad things
relative to the way the cameras work and
where they transmitted i don't know
what's happened over more recently but
apparently it's still an issue
i'm under i was always under the
impression
as a civilian that especially after 9 11
and you know from watching tv and movies
that there's this you know this crazy
ring and some place where you know
facial technology just captures every
new yorker everywhere they are in the
city and that um you know police can
just swoop down on anybody at any time
but i guess i'm i guess it's not there
yet
well i will i will tell you that
externally what's
used by the nypd uh works very well
i can't comment beyond what i just said
on the cameras in the
subways there's also all kinds of
transmission issues uh because of where
they are but uh again i was not at all
surprised that the cameras didn't work
it's been a perpetual issue with the mta
yeah and he was able once he well first
he got out of there on another train
across the tracks obviously they didn't
want to freeze those trains they were
using to get people out of the chaos
and then he was at least for a while
able to just kind of walk around the
east village in manhattan unbothered
well he did but you know uh there was
never any doubt in my mind that the nypd
would get him in within a day or so
i mean this was not a massive criminal
he
he left all kinds of identifying things
uh
at the crime scene and it was just a
matter of time before they got him yeah
another piece of nice detective work
helped by another citizen uh they found
this car key at the scene and they
pretty quickly quickly linked it to this
abandoned u-haul that was
uh called in by by a helpful tip
yup which he
again not a master criminal which he
paid for with a credit card right with
his name on it um
yeah
um this subway attack doesn't appear to
be directly related to
the rise in street crime in the city
other than other than murders pretty
much everything is up from a year ago
um
is it that some of is some of that just
that there's more people out and about
with with kobit restrictions lower or is
there is there some explanation in your
mind of why crime is up otherwise in the
city and other cities well is it very
very simple explanation in my mind at
least
we had eight years of a mayor who was
more interested in victims than in
criminals
and with the bail reform laws with the
emptying of the jails
with the defunding of police and the
demonization of police
uh you have created an atmosphere where
criminals are not afraid to commit
crimes you know when i was police
commissioner it was pretty clear if you
committed a crime everything from
jumping over a subway turnstile uh to
using a gun you're going to be
apprehended and you're going to go to
rikers and then you're going to go to
jail yeah
all of that over the last seven years
has disappeared
and unfortunately it's going to take
mayor adams and i'm hopeful
that he'll
start turning it around but you can undo
seven or eight years and a couple of
months
is there a balance um
justice wise socioeconomically
and just resource wise resource wise is
there a balance between
maybe bail reform going too far and and
a balance between giving poor people the
same justice system and so people aren't
in rikers
or pleading guilty to something they may
or may not have done just because they
can't afford the bail and and and
letting repeat criminals off the street
is there something better is there a
better way that you see yeah sure
there's a balance there's a balance if
somebody commits a is a first offender
and isn't a danger to the community
the judges
should have the discretion than they did
to let that person out uh there's also a
proportion of the criminal system
uh that that's their job they commit
crimes and those are the people who need
to be incarcerated and off the street
that has not happened for eight years
and that's unfortunate and that's why
you know
the there used to be 60 000 car thefts
in new york city when i left i think
there were 9 000 i think we're heading
in the direction of 60 000 again and you
know
shootings are way up and i have always
said that a shooting is a homicide was
with bad aim yeah so you know we we
unfortunately have a situation in new
york
where at least at this point criminals
think they can get away with things
something mayor something else mary
adams has been trying to do is
uh take care of
uh the homeless problem i guess for lack
of a better thing to call it um he's
been trying to get these encampments off
the streets it's not as bad as i
remember from when you were commissioner
and and even but especially before that
in the early 90s but it is certainly
more of a problem than it was i don't
know four or five years ago the number
of homeless people maybe the
belligerents of homeless people a lot of
these people refuse to go to shelters
talk about homelessness a little from a
police perspective i assume most
officers don't necessarily want this to
be their problem unless there's you know
a greater crime committed
no but you may not recall but i actually
created a homeless outreach unit of 100
police officers specially trained to
give assistance to the homework homeless
to understand their needs but most
importantly to get them off the street
and if they didn't want to get off the
street we made them get off the street
and i think that's the right thing to do
because sometimes unfortunately these
people these people have mental issues
which is not in their interests and we
don't want to see people freezing on the
street we don't want to see people
assaulting people on the street
homelessness is is a serious issue and
we paid a lot of attention to it and we
reduced it significantly that's all gone
um
this isn't your
uh not your city but the los angeles
police department uh just broadening
this out says street gangs 17 of them in
this case have been getting into these
coordinated follow home robberies
they're calling them in rich
neighborhoods where you follow people
home and then rob them once they get
there and they're off you know they're
sort of out of the public eye the last
year or so we've also been hearing a lot
more about these smash and grab
robberies where a bunch of people
overwhelm a high-end store and just grab
everything they can is this all
something new is there some evolving
critical criminal strategy here or is it
just something we're hearing about more
no it's an evolving criminal strategy
that's a reaction to the lack of
effective and assertive law enforcement
the lack of district attorneys charging
people with the right crimes and the
lack of putting people in jail after
they commit a crime with high bail if
it's a violent crime you know the
black lives matter anti-far the defund
police movement
have all sent signals and even our
president has come out in favor of some
of these things although he's turned
around recently but you know you send
that message
criminals listen to what law enforcement
is doing
and if they think that law enforcement
is going to be ineffective they're going
to commit more crimes the reason we
reduced homicides the way we did when i
was commissioner and commissioner kelly
who was commissioner commissioner
bratton was because criminals knew if
they carried a gun on the street the
probability is they were going to get
arrested so they stopped carrying their
guns on the street they knew if they
jumped over uh turnstile they were going
to get arrested so they stopped jumping
over turnstiles all of that went away
under the delazio administration
is there a problem on the other end with
now
with recruitment and retention and
if the atmosphere is so much worse
and in some cases the danger may be
worse is it harder to keep good cops and
attract good cops and maybe
and then the knock-on effect being that
the guys who are there the men and women
who are sticking around maybe aren't uh
always
the best
well you know
you make a good point with the
demonization of law enforcement it has
become very hard to recruit qualified
candidates
retirements are at the highest
level that they've been
for as long as i can remember and why
would somebody want to be a police
officer and be videotaped and doing
whatever he does at a relatively low
salary and everybody in the media
are demonizing them uh
it's a terrible atmosphere although i
will tell you i'm a little encouraged
because over the last month or so i've
seen
cities like portland and seattle
and los angeles and new york
suddenly changed their tune on defunding
police
because they've seen crime go through
the roof
and the fact is they're finally
realizing something that i've known
all along which is effective policing
matters
and if you don't have effective police
crime is going to go off the charts and
that's what we're seeing and it's not
going to turn around in one day
it's going to take a concerted effort to
get back to doing the things that
prevent criminals from committing crimes
howard safer chairman of safer
intelligence and security in the private
sector now former my uh new york city
police commissioner and fire
commissioner as well uh with the d.a u.s
marshals service before that so we
appreciate you coming on uh howard safer
thanks good to be with you
[Music]
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary coming up
fans know that kathie lee gifford has
never been shy about expressing her
faith but that's only a hint of what
happens behind the scenes conversations
the long time tv host and four-time emmy
winner is now sharing in a fox nation
series the jesus i know the guests are
from a variety of faiths and backgrounds
from patty millette justin bieber's mom
who talks about not giving him up for
adoption i just felt like i i need to
man up i need to grow up quickly
and figure this thing out mother up
mother up to tony award winner kristen
chenoweth who opens up about her
childhood up until just very recently
past couple years
i've been speaking out a little bit more
about being adopted mainly because i was
like i never want to hurt anyone's
feelings the series is based on
gifford's book of the same name writing
books is not my favorite thing
i'd much rather write a musical or a
just a country song or a gospel song or
direct to film but but god has been
using my books powerfully and so i
always listen to okay his voice you know
maybe lord if that's what you want me to
do next the premise of this book was
suggested by her literary agent it was
during covid so you know i wasn't uh as
busy doing the in in person kinds of
things that i do
so um he said kathy
all of these other books that we've done
together my favorite parts in them
is when you share your faith with people
like kevin costner or
craig ferguson or al pacino or you know
these people that are in your life just
naturally because that's the world i'm
from
he said i find those those in those
conversations fascinating now the man
who was telling me this is very
different from me he is man he is gay he
is asian and was raised buddhist
so he's not somebody that that you would
think is my doppelganger you know but i
love this guy he's fantastic and uh he
said i would would you consider
writing a whole book on with
interviewing people that are your
scientologist friends your agnostic
friends your your um maybe even atheist
friends or your
sikh and
hindu i have friends from every walks of
life and i think that every believer in
jesus should have
friends from every walk in life because
jesus did
he he didn't just hang out with the
people who looked exactly like him and
sounded like him and worshiped like him
he
went into everybody's world and saw
right into their hearts and loved them
and if we as followers of jesus would do
that with our own lives the world would
not look like it looks today
so many believers in uh of different
religions just judge other people
because they're different and jesus said
love one another as i have loved you he
didn't say love people that look just
like you and worship just like you he
said love your enemies
he said radical things that the world
had never heard before
and what he said to me the other day was
was quite profound and i don't know
where i'm going to use it yet but i've i
think it's going to be in a song with my
friends
louis york who are featured in this
special
i write with these guys a lot and and
they're just they're
they're so spirit-filled and spirit-led
and spirit-talented
and
so the lord gave me this and i hope it
blesses people he said kathy when you
meet someone
love them
and then keep loving them until you no
longer recognize them as the person you
met
wow because they will be so transformed
by the way you have loved them in my
name
there's no more powerful thing in the
world than love
and i'm still you can tell processing
what a message that was
you know and and that's what i wake up
in the morning and pray for and i fail
miserably at it every day lisa i just do
i wish i could love the way jesus loves
everyone
uh the older i get and the longer i walk
with him and learn about him the deeper
my love is for him therefore it it it
does spread
to more people it radiates from us when
we truly truly love jesus and walk in
his footsteps he never left anybody he
met the same
and so all these people that you'll meet
in my book 25 of them are completely
different
just the way god made them and five of
them are my guests on this uh special
called the jesus i know yeah the fox
nation series really
does dive a little more to some of the
conversations from the book um just to
give people a sense of the range singer
and actress christian chenoweth but
country star jimmy wayne you've got
fox's own janice dean
and um justin bieber's mom
yes so i'm wondering is
is and my friends aforementioned louis
york yes
is faith or sometimes the bumpy road to
faith or or with faith or through it
is that the common denominator here
i think the word i would use
is the common denominator is journey
every one of us are on a journey but our
journeys are different the roads we
travel are different
and that's not random in the jewish
tradition and in the hebrew language
there is no word for coincidence
that's because
the jews believe and i am jewish and i
am a jewish follower of jesus um
messianic what they call christians uh
because the jew the christian faith came
from the jewish faith and we are not
separate we began as one and many of us
continue the one love story of god for
his people but anyway in the hebrew
there's no word for
for coincidence because god is either
sovereign in all things
or he's not god at all so nothing is
random nothing is coincidence you know
there is no such thing as luck
if god is truly sees us all and is in
all things even the tragedies that
happen he didn't cause them but he is
there in them
and he is our way out of them as well
then then you'll never say i'll never
say good luck to somebody as long as i
live i say bless you or go with god but
never leave god out of the equation in
life in anything you do and any thought
you have any deeds you do
and that's the challenge of being a
follower of jesus
you're clearly inspired
by your faith um
is thank you for not using the word
obnoxious because that's what
a lot of people think but that's okay no
inspired i mean it radiates from you the
inspiration and the love and the faith
all of it
so is that what you're hoping
with
the fox nation special from your book is
that what you're hoping to do for others
is it you know what are you hoping
people get out of it
i'm hoping that people come away from
watching these in interviews with these
amazing people
wow if god loves them
i wonder if he loves me too
many of them have heartbreaking stories
of loss and damage and brokenness
and most people in the world have some
of that in their lives
and people lose hope and they lose faith
and they and they start to fall into
despair
i'm praying that those are the people
that watch this special or read this
book or any of my books and find hope
because god loves them and he doesn't
love me any more than he loves them he
loves us all equally
and god doesn't cancel you and god
doesn't give up on you because you've
made mistakes and god doesn't say i wish
you were never born no
god meant for you to be born and god
still has a plan for your life no matter
what you've done no matter where you've
come from
god loves you and he will never give up
on you trust him and let him give you
the life he always always intended for
you
i have to ask you this one question it's
a
far cry from these deep it's called
segway lisa
but it's an awkward one albeit it's
awkward but i'm curious do you miss
doing morning tv i don't i don't miss it
at all i did about 35 years of it and
i achieved a much greater success in it
than i ever dreamed i would
people said to me when i left regis and
then i left the the today show they
always say
how could you leave that your dream job
and they're just assuming that that was
my dream job it never was
it was a great job and i was grateful
for it and i loved it while i was doing
it but it was never my dream job how
could have been my dream job when when
talk show host did not exist when i was
growing up
they didn't or if they did later they
were all men
and um so i wanted to be an actress and
a singer from the day i was born
and i've never stopped being an actress
and a singer and then a writer and now
i'm a director and i'm an author and i'm
i do i do so many different things
because i'm so interested in so many
things but talk show host was never on
the list
god just wanted me there to use me
he wanted me there to use me because i
was fearless to share my faith
and i would share a scripture on the
today show i would share a scripture
with regis i would talk about
regis would talk about you know get
reading his horoscope and i would just
laugh with him i go reach richard i get
it you want to know i said but why
why do you stop at the stars why do you
put your faith in the stars how about
the one who made the stars duh and he'd
just laugh
and by saying that i was actually
quoting scripture
you know i was actually saying oh look
beyond
look beyond that to what's who created
it
so i always used opportunities like that
to share that there is a greater being
out there and he's not he's not just
this cosmic thing that doesn't see us
he's this everlasting thing from age to
age and forevermore who does see us
he's that kind of god and he's a living
god and he sees you
he is a womb to the tomb and beyond kind
of god and i've never put it that way
before but he is
he put my dreams in in me
while i was in my mother's womb
where her dreams were put in her in her
mother's womb and yours lisa were
putting you in your mother's womb
and god has a plan for your life because
he had a plan for your dreams all along
before you were even born
that gives me purpose every day
a lot of people have lost purpose in
their life too
where their children have left or their
husband or spouse has died and they no
longer feel needed
well if you're alive you still have a
pulse and you still have a purpose and
that means god needs you he needs you to
share
his message of love with others
well anyone who wants to be
uplifted or get some inspiration
the fox nation special is streaming the
jesus i know
and of course the book as well so kathie
lee gifford thank you so much we
appreciate your time thank you lisa god
bless you
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa rate and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
if you've been looking for a reason to
enjoy a national park near you that
reason is here national park week is
kicking off and to celebrate the
national park service says admission to
the parks is free on saturday april 16th
camping fees will still be charged
national park week runs through the 24th
and events are planned including special
programs and digital experiences this
year's national park week theme is spark
connections
spark
get it
park spark connection never
the very first national park week
happened in 1991 in celebration of the
national park service's 75th anniversary
there are more than 400 national parks
across the u.s and while some have
national park in their name like
yosemite yellowstone big bend and great
smoky mountains not all of them do you
can find one close to you by going to
nps.gov
in new york city home to 11 national
park sites tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind the aesthetics of
easter are bright we dress up in pastel
colored clothing we search for shiny
eggs full of candy and we take pictures
with life-sized bunnies but it all feels
a bit trite this year when we compare
this light-hearted fun with the grim
reality of what is unfolding in ukraine
the streets there are full of innocent
corpses shot down blown up or tortured
by russian soldiers but the original
good friday more than 2 000 years ago
was also a scene of horror and
devastation much like it is in ukraine
right now
the sun grew dark at midday earthquakes
shook the ground splitting rocks apart
and cracking tombs open as jesus hung on
a wooden cross
pierced and bleeding crying out my god
my god why have you forsaken me
i'm sure that many ukrainians hiding
amidst the rubble of besieged cities are
asking the very same question right now
where is god in all of this why won't he
intervene when we need him the most
the irony is that jesus was the answer
to his own question
on the cross god was intervening as john
3 16 tells us god so loved the world
that he gave his only son
the horrific suffering and death of the
cross was not the scene of an accident
it was the accomplishment of god's
mission
easter celebrates the fact that the son
of god himself underwent suffering in
order to save us and offer us eternal
life
for those in ukraine there is nothing
good in what is happening to them
they are enduring evil plain and simple
but i want to assure you that although
god's answer to their prayers may not
come immediately it will come ultimately
god's answer to the horrors of good
friday was delayed but not cancelled the
disciples endured the sorrow of christ's
death that friday afternoon
saturday must have felt like an eternity
to them
but then that first easter sunday came
when christ was gloriously resurrected
from the dead
because of what happened at easter we
can be assured that christ will someday
soon swallow up death forever and wipe
away tears from all faces as the
scripture promises
easter is god's guarantee that evil will
not triumph as the apostle paul wrote to
the corinthians if we trust in god we
will have the victory through our lord
jesus christ
may you and your family experience a
glorious and hope-filled easter
this is robert jeffress for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak i'm shannon breme host
of fox news at night and author of the
new book women of the bible speak the
wisdom of 16 women and their lessons for
today subscribe now on apple podcast
spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts